joining us once again here on the show
on this Monday spot is a football
morning in America column on NBC
sports.com and pro football talk is a
must-read and he is Peter King how you
doing Peter I'm hanging in there thank
you everybody happy and healthy we're
where I am so that's why I'm I'm sitting
here as always your columns must read so
you hectored chris ballard the general
manager of the colts into I guess
allowing you to virtually follow him I
mean how did you report what you did for
the Colts and how the general manager is
getting ready for this draft with zooms
and meetings and face times and all that
stuff I came up with this idea Ridge
last week that I mean I I had no idea
how these teams I I could sort of figure
that they're doing meetings by vision by
video conference and and all that but I
didn't really know so I put a few lines
in the water with teams and the Colts
agreed to allow me to chat you know in
the case of Frank Reich it was actually
by zoom video conference and in in in
with others it was simply by telephone
to sort of tell me tell me what your
week is like tell me what your day is
like tell me how are you doing your job
now so I got six people in the
organization to tell me exactly where
they're working from you know one of
their social media people amber Darrow
is working from her couch about five
miles from the cult complex and and
their offensive quality control guy has
decamped to his parents house in
northern Mississippi where he had to
make sure there was good Wi-Fi there in
Corinth Mississippi before he went there
but in general I just wanted to see
exactly how teams were working how they
were able to continue doing their jobs
and and rich I'll tell you one of the
interesting things at least to me you
know when the top 30 visits which are
vitally important to so many teams it's
honestly it's how Andy Reed got to be
smitten with Patrick Mahone
he had him for a day in the cold sky in
the Chiefs complex in Kansas City in
2017 and and basically that convinced
him to take my homes to trade up and
take them well they're not going to have
that this year so how are they doing it
well in succession they basically have a
series of one-hour meetings either by
zoom or face timer
maybe Cisco WebEx Microsoft teams
whatever their video conference of
choices and they do that and they have a
maximum of 1 hour per team employee that
they can talk to this guy and then at
the end of 3 hours they're done and
they're going to make their decision so
everybody is going to say grab a coke
with it
it's just and and the Colts aren't
complaining they're simply saying here
is our new fact of life and rich I just
wonder especially to atong of Aloha
think about it
how is a team going to be really
comfortable with picking him when
they're doctors and they cannot get
their hands on him to do a complete and
thorough physical of that hip and those
two ankles so in that front though
didn't he have some sort of medical
recheck that that all team doctors were
able to I guess chime in on that okay so
that that doesn't check that box you
don't think potentially I don't know
rich I mean I still think that there's a
lot of these teams that they want to
look their own orthopedist in the face
right and say listen yeah we're going to
pick this guy with what the second third
fourth nine to pick in this draft and
and we're gonna and and and first of all
we can't even get them in our own
facility to sit down and talk football
with them even though I'm sure a lot of
people have already done some things
like that all I'm saying is it's doable
but it's scary Peter King here on the
Rich Eisen show so what's the status in
terms of where all teams are gonna be
or for the draft obviously some teams
are still maybe in their team facilities
I had Sean Payton on last Wednesday and
he's like hey man I just stroll into
work it's our first day here at a
brewery and say the dixie brewery and in
New Orleans East and you know the the
Benson's on it and we're kind of setting
up shop here where anybody that's that
that can come to work and they're
healthy enough to come to work and
they're not exposed because they have
pre-existing conditions they're welcome
here everybody else has to have their
temperature check before we walk in here
like that's the the new normal or is
everybody just gonna have to be forced
to do it from home Peter what do you
know about that right I think I think at
the end of the day it's I think it's
going to be one of two things I think
every team is either going to have to be
at home or individually or at some
location not in the facility but like
that brewery where people some number
you know five six seven whatever the
maximum the NFL will allow be in a place
where they can be distant from each
other but still in the same room now if
you ask me my gut feeling today I think
it'll all be individuals working out of
individual homes really and then you're
going to have to worry about as kevin
demo off of the rams totally less the
encryption technology of some of these
video conference services because
obviously you know zoom has come under
some scrutiny for not having the best
security and encryption so look there's
all these issues in rich I'll tell you
what's going on with the NFL right now
so today is August a plus six and April
six is is when all new coaches around
the NFL are supposed to start their
offseason program and as of last night
the NFL had not distributed rules for
the new coaches and their offseason
program and and
one person involved with one of these
teams said when I asked him this weekend
about it we have no idea what the rules
are and so you know they the NFL is like
that dog that you see out in the middle
of a lake who looks perfectly calm but
it's paddling like a madman so that he
doesn't go under and that's what the NFL
is trying to do right now with all these
things that they never expected to be
issues three weeks ago
huh and I've got Sean McVeigh on at the
end our number two Oh
I'll ask him exactly what he knows right
now and what he's planning on and and he
doesn't know anything about April 20
except just like the Colts I'm sure he's
planning right to basically have his
offensive and defensive players
separately on videoconferencing so that
they can learn their playbook for X
number of hours in the course of a week
they're gonna they're discussing with
the NFL PA what the rules are and all
that but it's all just right now anyway
it's sort of mayhem so in terms of the
rules for that to Peter King here on the
Rich Eisen show it would be essentially
what like a certain eliminated of hours
that a player would have to be make
himself available for this sort of stuff
as opposed to no rules that you got to
be on and in the same way that are you
and are you saying there could be zoom
holdouts contractual zoom holdouts Peter
you know a rich if we are not allowed to
get out of our houses and our apartment
right and our homes by the end of July
man I'll tell you one thing I don't
think we're gonna have an NFL season to
worry about that's all I can say well
I'm just saying that worried about
worried about no I'm just saying though
is that you know my I haven't saw my
tender so I'm not zooming in I'm holding
out of the zoom meetings you know I mean
like that's a really good question and
what will that Prescott do in Dallas he
refuses to know if Mike McCarthy is
installing and and Kellen Moore are
installing the new offense over zoom
what
they not gonna have their quarterback on
it I guess is of right now they wouldn't
have their quarterback on it but I don't
know I guess it's a different way of I
guess paraphrasing the old joaquin
andujar right yeah if I ain't signed
I ain't zoom and you know I mean like
that's the way it might have to be Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show all
right you just mentioned about you know
if we're not out of our homes by July
obviously we're taking the viruses cues
on things the Commissioner was one of
many commissioners that was on the phone
with the president over the weekend what
are you hearing about the NFL's stance
on all this are there discussions
somewhere somewhere sometime about about
all of those contingency plans right now
Peter I don't see how they can't have
any serious discussion right now the
only thing they can do is prepare but I
wrote my column today rich is that
knowing Howard Katz
and his schedule team right yeah these
diligent guys who live it for four
months like Mike North and Ani Bo's and
all those people on that on their team I
would be shocked if they aren't in there
right now working on 12 and 14 game
versions of the schedule that if they
need to on August first they can pull
out of their drawer and say okay we're
starting that we're starting the NFL
season on October 18 it's going to be 12
weeks in the regular season
no buys and we're going to have a
limited number of fan and fans in the
stands and here here's the schedule and
everybody said well big deal why don't
you just lop off the first say four
weeks
well the difficult thing with that I
would think is you would probably want
to have all of your division games
played in either a 12 or 14 game
contracted compacted version of the
schedule so you know the NFL isn't used
to not having any division games in the
first four weeks of a season so they're
probably going to have to go to work and
see if
one of those things can be done rich and
that's just that's a guess on my part
but having the extra month or three
weeks now to do the schedule right it
would be foolish for the NFL not to be
considering alternatives like that Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show I saw
because I follow Rick Stroud who covers
the Bucs
in Tampa he tweeted out Jameis Winston
doing a PSA with a doctor to try and
raise money locally still and it just
shows you how his mindset is still
focused on his own community and just
being somebody who's out there in the
community and I can only think that's
also something that he wants to show
teams that I can do this for you too
alright and and again I'm sure his
altruism comes from every fiber of his
being that's what he has definitely
shown in the last couple years if not
maybe longer for those who know him a
little bit better than me I just bring
that up too because he and Cam Newton
are still sitting out there what in the
world is happening with those two guys
and we all know the spots that could use
them we don't know if they're gonna do
that before the draft what can you tell
me here now less than three weeks before
the draft about those two guys rich I
don't think there's any hurry for teams
with these guys because now the the
frenetic stuff has stopped now that Nick
Foles has gone to the bears Phillip
Rivers has gone to the Colts Teddy
Bridgewater Tom Brady and I'm sure I'm
missing one or two but I think now it
has become very clear that the New
England Patriots might sign a veteran
quarterback might but if they do it'll
be a their price tag and at their time I
think now the two biggest teams that you
really wonder about is being in the
market for both Cam and Jameis Winston
would be the Jacksonville Jaguars in the
Los Angeles chargers but if I am either
one of those teams I wouldn't want to
sign either one of those quarterbacks
until after this draft and I mean if
somebody asked me that this week what do
you the other day what do you think is
going to happen to those guys and and
and and here's the only reason I say
that let's say that Dave Caldwell and
Doug Marrone of the Jacksonville Jaguars
really like Justin Herbert okay and on
draft day Justin Herbert pulls and Aaron
Rodgers and they're the Jacksonville
Jaguars sitting there with the 20th pick
in the first round the pick acquired you
know in the trade for Jalen Ramsey with
the Los Angeles Rams at number 20 what
if Justin Herbert sitting there and what
if they love them and what if they say
jeez man I wish we didn't sign miss
Winston that we'd rather have Justin
Herbert to draft and develop so it
doesn't make any sense for me in my mind
you know similarly the Chargers are
sitting there at 37 or even at 6 really
with Herbert or at 37 would say Jordan
love her or from or Eason or maybe they
love one of those guys how do we know
and he's sitting there at 37 and they
can pick their guy the long term future
so that's why I'm not saying I don't
think I'm not saying I absolutely don't
think it'll happen but I might my
expectation is that both of those guys
will probably find a home sometime in
the spring and to me Cam Newton I would
think he'd find a home sometime after a
team could have its own doctors
examining him and finding out exactly
how his foot is and how his shoulder
this no that's not gonna be for some
time I mean we're you're talking maybe
like you know potentially the summer or
something like that based on everything
we read and write I agree but but rich
is you can see we can see which way the
wind is blowing on all of this stuff
okay and in in my opinion I mean I doubt
that any team is going to have any sort
of mini camp at all this year
okay right and they will be fortunate to
have any kind of training camp I think
and if all that is the case and I mean I
just this is
this is this is a tangible thing it's
not like they're being forced to make a
decision tomorrow on to a ton of Aloha
they're not being forced to do that
because to a Tong evallo year decision
has to be made by April 23rd right or
else somebody else will take them it's
not that way with Cam Newton but that it
then let's just play this whole thing
out if that happens then the competition
that's the healthy competition as it was
termed by the bears last week between
foals and and true Biscay won't play out
before they the bears make a decision on
Travis Keys fifty or option right so how
does that all play out there's no way
that they can they can exercise that
option how how possibly could the
there's nothing that they would see in a
mini camp right nothing I heard I heard
Ryan pace and those guys talked about
that last week they they're not going to
know whether they're bringing the true
Biscay back by whatever the date is this
spring thing they've got a way they
they're not going to exercise that I
would be shocked well is that is that
theories that's the sort of stuff that
is being discussed between the PA and
the NFL right now about about what the
rules are in the art but could they
relax those zero reporting on that so I
just don't know just don't know all
right ask Peter they polled question
before we let him hit the road the about
the draft Christopher yeah yeah Peter
which virtual draft room would you most
want to peek inside
Cowboys Patriots Dolphins we threw the
Giants on their dolphins without any
question three picks in the first round
very likely to get their long-term
quarterback and in my opinion in my
opinion if burrow is markedly above the
other quarterbacks on their board they
should offer four ones to the bengals to
move up five to one say the phone didn't
break up I heard you but say that again
for ones like for borough is that really
what you think yes I'm saying yes thing
on the Dolphins draft board Joe burrow
is number one and the other quarterbacks
well whoever's number two you know
Herbert to whoever whoever it is if
there is a significant drop-off between
one and two on their quarterback board
then I would trade five eighteen twenty
six and one of their two first-round
picks next year to the bengals for Jill
burrow but I'd want to zoom into that Oh
drag him to maybe that's why I'm not a
general manager if I see a wedding photo
of you and Ricky Williams on the cover
of a magazine
after all this then I'll know that that
this was your idea
I'll know that man I remember that
remember that Ditka and Ricky Williams
photograph on the cover of ESPN's yeah
Peter you take care of yourself let's
chat next week okay thanks again okay
lots to unpack there from Peter King